hello and welcome to zero playing Villa
vinyl Villa vine yo probably didn't
pronounce that correctly e5 oh wow
players a gambit gambit so here begins
those gambits you want to develop
quickly but ok 9 p-5 this Bishop before
doesn't do anything and i wonder if i
should actually develop my bishop
outside of the chain or not stuff like
that maybe let's do it so that it cannot
castle immediately and Bishop g3 is this
something here it looks very slow all
right if I go pick up g3 let's let's
develop a little bit more even take five
so what's the deal wants to go to h5 or
yeah ok now that's actually an idea
night to be four also might be an idea
yeah queen age five is somewhat annoying
if a dad hits and Bishop g3 blunders the
house hmm this is actually not not so
great
so how do I play this it's not easy it's
nice d for maybe a move it looks really
strange I shut my mouth he should be
tuned I just got three nage fire huh he
really tricked me with this with this
with this opening no didn't do it okay
maybe I'm still lost somehow and what is
strange opening and now a seven is
attacked still looks like I could loosen
me at least it tooks very very tricky
yeah some people Quincy to wear stuff
like that Bishop d3 is that okay if I
take a seven what's the deal yes this
Queen cysts see to business this is
really a problem when you fall I'm
immediately losing
it should be should be three I can just
take it with the Queen and then I take a
g4 what kind of nonsense is that oh my
check I might still be lost year after
f5 yeah I'm probably lost after a five
we're def in a move actually f5 I and I
and I resign I think
don't even have something to continue
the game is the worst part okay this is
lucas attacked the some kind of tactic
rope t1 bishops III actually i can go do
you want yeah for buddy can just take
the queen just like that anyway you can
just take the Queen and it's over
you
yeah I'm just a just a rope down here
okay white resigns yeah it always feels
bad against an opening like that which
is yeah it just shouldn't work at all
yeah but this is strong I mean this is
just very difficult to to play against
so what what am I actually doing wrong I
mean that get stuck let's check yeah
maybe this Bishop g5 is still it's
losing too much time that's really
possible yeah maybe you three Bishop b2
castles IAM speeding up the development
I mean this is not enough compensation
for a center porn it's oublie it doesn't
work but you have to play correctly and
probably I just didn't as simple as it
sounds I just played it badly yeah I had
my doubts with Bishop g5 but still fell
it makes sense to develop an outside of
the pawns but it's a difficult position
he already after Queen a fire I mean I
plated plate this really badly now also
but it is a it is a difficult position
it's not easy to play the engine wants
to play age 3 air but I didn't really
see what to do here with the engine
gives this this check check and check in
your black has a draw in hand but
probably more right it's a super
difficult position to play I mean what I
played simply doesn't doesn't work he
can't play Queen age five but she didn't
but this also seems to win red wins for
black n 94 I was I certainly didn't want
to check
so completely losing yeah I did I didn't
see my original my original idea here
was of course is just to develop yeah
but you you probably don't yeah I mean
this is the problem I cannot play this
now okay so Bishop g5 is the problem
this is just totally bad yeah but should
you five it takes far too much time and
and it has to be avoided I just cannot
play it I think like g3 is given by the
comp something like that or h3 also III
I mean you just have to do complete
development here it's hard to believe
that some temper here compensate for
Center porn this is a difference if you
give up like some bee pollen orgy porn
or whatever and the sender corn so I
don't believe in this compensation here
but we have seen that it is definitely
dangerous here maybe I should have
played Bishop g3 year but it's not easy
here absolutely not yeah or can you do
thanks for watching